in america's deep south
a stretch of the mississippi with its
own notorious nickname we call this
cancer alley
where poor black communities say they're
being poisoned by mile after mile of
heavy industry
we are nothing we're not people that
live here
now plans for a huge new plastics plant
threatened the skies over louisiana
and the people are fighting back i'm
gonna be here
to fight till i die to make sure that
another plant don't come here but can
they take on big industry
and win
over the mississippi and into cancer
alley as the people who live here call
it
where the billboards say it all and
where for mile after mile
petrochemical plants belch out fumes and
pollution
wedged between them poor largely black
communities
trapped unable to move and they say
becoming
increasingly sick it's hard for living
here
you know knowing that uh you won't make
it to be old age
you know like our ancestors that we they
live to be
90 95 and now you have people dying at
36 on up you know
even younger
you know the kids is our tomorrow and
with what's going on now we're worried
about the kids
uh getting cancer
[Music]
the houses and chemical plants are in
amongst each other
people living under the shadow of their
industrial neighbors
in one of the most heavily polluted
areas in america
i'm so hurt you know every day is a cry
and now we have the covet on top of
cancer
it is it's you don't even want to leave
out your house in the morning
and it smells y'all just don't know how
we have a smell
comes here when those plants are
escaping
gases and all the stuff they're letting
out
janna's first show is typical of most
people you talk to here
they either have cancer or know many
others who do and they blame it on the
pollution
it's me myself my brother
my sister i have uh about
eight cousins and my neighbor
uh and it's it's a quite bit more but
at least for sure in this area where i'm
at is 20.
all have cancer who has cancer i'm just
happy that the lord took it away from my
body
but i got a little cousin she stay in
the project
this child is in her 30s and
she had to have both of her breasts
removed my sister had to have both of
her breasts
and that chemo is just tearing them down
a new un report has condemned what's
happening in cancer alley
as environmental racism a legacy of
slavery
the industrial plants are built on
plantation land
and many in the poor black communities
who live work and worship here
are descendants of slaves still getting
a raw deal
they're the weakest people they're the
poorest people and they
often not the most educated people so we
put the plant there
you know and the plantation mentality
has been here
many of these plants are located on all
plantations
so this goes back a long way it goes
back a long way
a long way and it's very disappointing
but it's time to turn it around
but far from turning it round the state
has given permission
for the biggest plant yet it goes from
that
from that pole over there where you see
all the electric crackers they did the
electrical work
lead from there all the way to the blue
sign down here and all it's going to be
for mosul
and as with this plant coming
and that plant right there we're on a
time bomb
taiwanese company foremost of plastics
plans one of the biggest plastic plants
in the world here
covering two and a half thousand acres
but not without a fight
from local people i have a list of
people
that have already died from cancer then
i have a list
of people who are dying with cancer as
we speak
i feel like our turn is coming i know
there's something
harsh to say but in my heart i feel like
that
fed up with watching friends dying from
cancer high school teacher sharon levine
has mobilized her community against the
formosa plant
i feel bad inside because it's a it's a
death sentence
i feel like it's a death sentence and i
feel like
if mimosa comes here they want us to die
off
they want us to just pack up and leave
the people don't have the funds to
pack up and leave and go somewhere else
i don't have the funds either
so they they're not offering to buy
anyone out they just plan to come here
and just
build and put their filth on us so
they don't care about the people they
don't care about human lives
and how much are you prepared to fight
that i'm gonna fight to the
end yes indeed that plant gonna be two
miles from my house
they must be losing their mind god put
the right person here to fight
god put the fight in me this is my home
this is my people and i'm gonna fight
for me and my people
but it's not just cancer-causing
chemicals from the proposed plant
that are causing concern if it's built
it's estimated the new plastics plant
will be
pumping into the atmosphere something
like two and a half million
cars worth of carbon a year making it
one of the biggest single sources of
carbon in america
and contributing to something already
causing problems down in the mississippi
delta
climate change
we took to the waters on an airboat to
see the impact climate change is having
on louisiana's coastline diggers are
trying to claw back marshland beyond the
levees
lost to rising water levels this
excavator is lifting the mud out of this
borough ditch
hampering the work an unprecedented five
hurricanes have swept through in the
last year
blamed by many scientists on climate
change it's like they all come in one
it was bam bam bam you know like one
came we got out of here we came back
another one came we got out here we came
back another one came we got out here we
came back it was just
repetitious over and over further down
the coast is a place called phoenix
ravaged not by fire but by those five
hurricanes in the last year
showing little respect for anything in
their path
it's a worry when you leave you don't
know if you're coming home to anything
it's hard i mean it's hard to
do four or five times a year
i know the hurricanes they're getting
worse they're getting worse and they're
getting more frequent
i'm sure it's because of things that's
happening around the world
the wind was so strong with the tornado
type wind that we had it just
kenny bartellomy also watched his
neighbor's trailer get trashed
by storms he says that are only getting
worse
it just seemed like they're getting more
frequently
and powerful as time go on
and just like every time they come it
just seems like it's more and more
more and more powerful more and more
damage so people
watching might think why do you live
here kenny why do you live in a place
that's hit by hurricanes so often
you know i just feel like you can't run
from god's work
so just gotta deal with it
in a statement to sky news formosa
plastics insisted its new plant
meets all regulatory criteria using
advanced emissions reduction mechanisms
and extensive measures to protect the
environment the state of louisiana says
great care is taken in the site
selection process to identify locations
that safeguard communities and their
residents state and federal regulators
require an extensive environmental
permitting process before construction
can begin
and they say plans for new plants are
subject to public consultation
but america's new president joe biden
has singled out
cancer alley by name as somewhere
environmental justice
needs to be addressed the people who
live there
say they'll hold him to his word it's
time to put a stop to the plants
and even before they start breaking
ground it's time to stop
enough is enough how much more can we
stand
we dying slowly they're killing us
slowly
and my question to everyone
why are you making our area a sacrifice
zone dominic waghorn
sky news louisiana